this takes me into what Pineapple
Express did that's the part where you
brought up and said Pat this entire time
people are thinking we have to rely on
somebody to do something this is a group
of civilians that are like listen dude
we don't care we're not waiting on you
we're going to go out there and do this
right you want to unpack what happened
with those guys so the listeners can
kind of yeah so for people that don't
know there's a bunch of ex-veterans
they're uh they're no longer active duty
or the ones that are active duty refuse
to identify themselves obviously because
they pretty much broke International
treaties and they they committed an act
of War by invading a sovereign country
but really these are guys that were on
uh that did multiple tours in
Afghanistan these are special forces
guys that got sick and tired of waiting
for the government to get their allies
and people who help them people who
helped say their their lives translators
particularly in their families uh out of
Harm's Way so they just went in they
said screw it we're not waiting for
clearance I mean this is like a 1980s
like like Arnold Schwarzenegger movie
this is like Predator this is like
hardcore old school America is the best
movie stuff here but these are real guys
who went in and they saved between 500
and a thousand people they got them
across the borders out of Afghanistan
and then uh we'll never know who they
are because obviously they're they're
technically war criminals now but these
guys are heroes we know how some of them
are because they talked about it a
couple of them a couple of them came out
in Florida they talked about it and Tim
Kennedy apparently was very uh very very
big and organizing it and and uh that
guy's a freaking stud you know Tim is a
special guy
do you have opinions on that or did you
yeah there's a lot going on I think um
look anyone as an American or even as a
citizen of the world should just look at
this and just be like there's a complete
[ __ ] show but what did we expect it's
almost like we don't learn any lessons
look back in history what the hell
happened in Vietnam America you can get
into a war very easily but I think we
realize it's very hard to get out of a
ward it's very ugly to get out of a war
I think something that we need to
recognize is what's the lesson here we
can be anti-terrorist badass mother
suckers and get in and take care of
business but we cannot build Nations
we're not Nation Builders we can't go
into goddamn middle of the Middle East
and think that they're going to come to
around to our way of thinking it didn't
happen in Iraq it's definitely never
happened in Iran it's not happening in
Afghanistan let's learn our lesson so
the next time that something happens
here God forbid a 9 11 happens we don't
rush to judgment 30 days later and
declare war in Afghanistan when like you
said before we're fighting at the
al-Qaeda but Al-Qaeda was our friends in
a different war and now now we're
fighting the Taliban but now we're
making peace with the Taliban because
they're fighting Isis K who's like
basically the Delta variant of Isis and
it's like we can't figure this out and
we never will we don't understand that
way of the world the government though
like it's from the inside I mean
obviously you have what was his name
sheller he goes online and he starts
speaking out and this guy's getting hit
pretty hard internally
so I you know obviously it starts from
the inside like when Pat you like you
talk about like we can't really do
anything about this this starts inside
we don't know if there's coups involved
in in our own freaking government all
the different branches we see inside
inside America absolutely you're telling
me that they don't have like there's
drama within our own government clearly
it's our own military clearly there's
different special interests because how
in the hell does this take place
let me let me ask you this so you just
you just made a point about hey we can
never solve this and this is Prime's
always going to be here it's always been
there it's not all the stuff that you
said okay fine yes but that's not that's
not the challenge right now that we
didn't get here because nobody agreed on
leaving the left and the right and the
middle everybody said we got to leave
there isn't anybody that's disagreeing
on stain except for the five to ten
percent of the veterans who are actually
there who saw what happened who have
emotional Affinity to the people there
that want to see their lives changed and
they feel like maybe we're a generation
away except from the True Believers 80
to 90 percent of America all agrees on
let's bring the troops back fine but
here's a question for you here's a
question for you okay so uh what is the
right way you're at a club okay there's
a shooting you're at a club there's a
shooting you hear a shot goes out what's
the right way to leave the club
what do you look for when you leave the
club the nearest exit the nearest exit
and you leave okay let me ask you a
question do you look for your friends or
do you I'm just going to run they're
going to find they're going to find a
round a way to run as well I'd like to
think I grab my friends who are around
me now let me ask you a question here
but if you're if you're with your
buddies and they're all athletes you're
probably like dude you're gonna find a
way out dude let's go guys fellas let's
get the hell out of here right in the
spur of the moment are you thinking
where's Jim where's where's Bob let me
flip it on yeah let me flip it on you
let me flip it on you you're at them all
with your two kids
there's a there's a fire you hear a shot
what's the first thing you're thinking
about grab your kids grab your kids and
then you leave right okay great you're
in your house there's a fire
you got two cats you got a dog and you
got two kids okay fire breaks out one of
the uh propane blows up and fires
everywhere what are you doing before you
leave the house trying to stop the fire
trying to stop the fire but you're
trying to get everybody out first right
is it fair to say that common sense says
what we gotta get the hell out right
there is no common sense that says don't
get out so the problem isn't we got to
get out the problem is how we get out of
here so you have to prioritize on how
you get out by the way here's a question
for you if you see if you're sitting in
a room you know shit's about to go down
what's the best thing you got to do if
you know the the enemy right there is
about to do something crazy what's the
best way for you to react
let's just say I text you I'm like hey
uh shit's about to go down Adam uh Phil
uh Gerard in a text guys uh we have five
minutes to get out of here leaving four
you grab your [ __ ] weapon no and make
sure you have them but but the way
you're gonna leave you're gonna be like
guys let's not overreact just like just
slowly just like okay so the way we're
gonna do it is you're gonna say I'm
gonna go to the bathroom and then
Gerard's gonna be like you know what I
gotta call let me call my girl yeah and
then gradually I'm like so slowly you go
out you're like okay dude like that's
how we left because we left like that so
the whole point isn't let's leave we
know we need to leave we know we need to
leave the demo how we left so okay so
now uh leaving Afghanistan for dummies
okay let's read that book leaving
Afghanistan for dummies okay let's let's
somebody should publish that book step
number one you got 85 billion dollars of
equipment yeah
okay
um civilians gotta go first so first of
all we need to equipment so Elaine's
gotta go first those translators those
interpreters well yeah gotta go first
then what goes next
in my opinion the troops go last I agree
with you okay but I don't know why we
put out the troops and we're like oh by
the way but we forgot a hundred thousand
civilians and all our [ __ ] so so it's
ass backwards but think about how much
of this is just pure common flipping
sense because it's it's reaction versus
response when you react you do what they
freaking did when you respond that means
that you're more calculated period and
they did not have I don't know when
we're kids like you have a fire drill
yeah like you have certain protocol
systems all that other crap
where was theirs where where was that
list here's the other part here's the
other part if you think about this okay
there's a part that I don't agree with
the president saying what we're about to
do next too early here's what I think I
think it's like listen guys I don't know
probably in the next uh to two to four
years we're going to try to leave
Afghanistan there you go but you leave
in six months but nobody needs to know
that you don't have a president sit up
there yeah here's my card hey guys we're
leaving in the next week oh [ __ ] they're
about to leave in the next week like
look we're gonna try to go on the next
two to four years we'll see what's gonna
happen Okay and we'll see what's going
to take place but we are working on it
we have a plan we'll see what will
happen then you know you're about to
leave in the next 30 days there's a part
of this that's strategically buddy it
just validates whoever is that's in the
commander of Chief position president
position
they're hacked they have to be strategic
they have to understand the Art of War
they have to understand power and then
the subtle maneuvering you don't just go
and say hey I don't know I'm just no I
mean you said it you said it a while ago
on a podcast I believe last time I was
here
uh that the commander-in-chief needs to
have some experience serving in the
military because of what you just said
I mean if they if he had some level of
experience of expertise he would
actually have to know
The Art of War all these things that you
described or or you know how we do it
let's just say you don't okay let's
because we're going to go in an era
where a guy's going to be a president
like a trump Biden Bush let's just say
these guys here's how it works you're
the final vote
but you got a board of six seven you're
one of the votes but you're the
executive chairman when it comes if
you've never served in the military
you're going to put generals there
uh Marines Air Force Army everybody
that's your National Security you put
your National Security Council and right
there the vote is for
if four in that room say boom go but
it's not one Biden doesn't get a chance
to vote neither Trump neither any of
these guys yeah you sit there and say
boom let's get out a few things that
that really come to mind from this thing
is the way Biden's handled it really
makes me feel like he's not running the
show he's a puppet I'm not supposed to
answer questions I'm not supposed who
you're the president who's telling you
what to do yeah if anything you should
be standing up with your chest out and
saying like but it's it's very obvious
and I'm not and that's not like I'm not
trying to knock Biden on this now I'm
like legitimately concerned who's
calling the shots here man that's number
one absolutely number two all right is I
think it's beyond obvious now like you
said it before what are we learning from
this why why we can't Nation build Adam
I don't think they ever intended to I
think that they were there to to suck
millions and millions of dollars and
keep these incredibly high paying jobs
why do they not care about eight billion
dollars worth of ordinance being left
behind because it wasn't their money
they don't care air it didn't come out
of their pocket that stuff was already
bought and paid for and in fact the
defense contractors are like let them
have it we got to buy new stuff
absolutely they don't want to win these
wars they just want to keep them going
for as long as possible this thing made
them I don't disagree so much money and
the Patriot Act Right we have the
Patriot Act we have TSA now they said
they're trying to spin it they're trying
to spin this that we don't need to be
there anymore because we we we hit the
objective it was Osama bin Laden was the
objective okay well then the Patriot Act
was there because of Bin Laden and Al
Qaeda and now you're telling us the
Taliban have learned their lesson so why
do we still have to go through TSA why
are we still doing all that BS is that
just again now what does that mean to me
with everything we're doing today that
was the quote unquote New Normal yeah
and that was supposed to go away but now
the Patriot Act is never going away
right we live in a surveillance stage
just like taxes it's never going away so
learn from learn what do you your to
your point Adam what can we learn from
this be very very careful which freedoms
you give away in in terms of well I just
want to feel safe because we're learning
right now and when the crisis is over
that you're not getting them back it's
not happening let me add to your point
you you've talked about Talk use this
term the military industrial complex
it's a real thing
I see what's going on here so something
that Pat always says here that we
learned anyone who starts with
valuetainment says
treat the company's money like it's your
own do you not say that Pat treat the
company's money so if you're going to go
out and get a hotel you're going to get
a car rental you're going to get
equipment you're going to get whatever
you're going to treat it like it's your
own and you're not going to waste your
spending save that money and it's just
disgusting to see how much waste and
fraught is going on there with within
government spending yeah it's disgusting
so let's Circle back to the original
question what were they supposed to do
with this equipment if they weren't
they're not how they getting tanks back
how are they getting bombers back this
see I've never been in the military but
it seems obvious rather than letting
them have it don't you just blow that
[ __ ] up why wouldn't you explain to me
why you wouldn't just
what you said is what Trump said
what's I don't know if you're what Trump
said he said here's a plan
first you get the civilians out yes then
you get the interpreters out let's just
say the Allies then you get some of the
equipment out then you blow every unit
up you blow it up because if there's any
anything you blow every base up that we
have then we get the troops that come
back up yeah that was this formula on
how to do it so you were just aligned
with Trump I'm not even making this a
president I'm aligned with Trump I'm a
line of Biden thing like you said
wait a minute you're aligned with common
sense sure great awesome that's a first
for me Right Bingo no it's not here we
go it's not a first for you if if if
Americans actually looked at this
[ __ ] they're not from the standpoint
of who's playing but rather from Common
Sense we many people would be on the
same side I agree but my point is this
forget about Trump forget about Biden
forget about Bush forget about Obama
because they're all guilty and they're
all we're involved in this War I mean
starting from Bush Obama is but the
generals
you're the ones calling the shots yeah
you're the ones in there saying look
I've been in war I've been in
Afghanistan for 20 years here's what we
need to do
who's the loudmouth General out there
talking right now it's so easy to blame
Biden or it's so easy to blame Trump and
Trump did the deal and Biden just went
through with the so easy why aren't the
generals it's hard for them because they
all they went all in on the
establishment to get rid of trump so
it's hard it's very hard for a guy like
Mattis who I'm a big fan of it's very
hard for him right now to be like I I
backed the wrong horse uh you know it's
very very difficult but the point is
this like who cares that you're talking
about America I agree with you yeah but
this is residential but this is also
when you say that who cares stuff again
like this is uh you know
because because it's in this moment
you've been so vilified in this in this
divisive political environment like this
is what I'm saying when I talk about I
don't want taxes taxes are theft and
people like I don't mind paying my fair
Sheriff it means that a kid can read and
education gets better and there's no
childhood
with their Warby Parkers
no it's not this is what your tax money
goes to your tax money doesn't your tax
money doesn't go to kids getting books
in schools your tax money goes to this
so until these people tell you and show
you that they can use the hours of your
life we've discussed this taxes aren't
just money money represents the hours of
your life that is eight billion hours of
American lives left behind for the enemy
to play around with and hang people from
Apache freaking helicopters that's
subsidized by you and me guys that right
there High Five Guys we didn't we
sponsored that and we're not going to
talk about this like my question is how
long are we going to continually talk
about this to drive that point home to
the general public because there's a lot
of people in this world that don't pay
attention to politics in this way they
don't pay attention to military in this
way this type of news needs to be
continuously over and over and there
that
there's a lesson to be learned in this
and we're all discussing it right here
but until that becomes like the norm
we're going to do this [ __ ] again the
other lesson we learned I know we're
going to talk about we avoid I know
we're going to talk about this but the
other lesson we learned is every time
they tell you that you can't take on the
government like all these Second
Amendment guys we got f-16s yeah yeah
right they got everything I'm laughing
in Farsi I laugh in North Vietnam yeah
you're telling me that I'll give up my
guns because why because with Eric
swalwell you don't have nukes yeah what
did the Taliban have
don't ever ever you forget you're a
second amendment you know they said the
Taliban officially moved up 161 spots in
the strongest military in the world
a hundred from our stuff from our stuff
161 spots yeah in the strongest military
in the world so that means they're like
in the top 50 right now can I think
about that the taliban's military after
what they just took is in the top 50
militaries in the world right now what
is their ties and I'm just going off
here like what are their ties with the
Communist Party in China
do they have any ties with that well
they have ties with Pakistan and then
Pakistan has ties I'm just talking I'm
just thinking in regards to like
technology and stuff like that it's a
good thought because this is this is all
a proxy because if yeah because I'm
thinking well like okay like it's
responsible for this who's responsible
for everybody's got to be responsible
for something who's last night you know
I had a conversation together right we
had a little bit of a hiccup and we're
talking to each other you're like yeah
you know what how my hair got too high
by the way yeah it's a funny story
behind that I like the hairs so we're
talking hey so okay but the point is who
who gets the responsibility on this atom
who gets the responsibility on this are
you looking for a figurehead or well you
listen I mean you know everything Rises
and falls on leadership who's
responsible for this look I I if you
want to go the easy clear answer Biden
and he's uh he even went out and said
look this is on me he said this
um what should be the repercussions well
the voters will determine that well but
we can't wait that long but what I'm
asking you is what I'm not getting
impeached it's not like none of that
okay it's not happening so let me ask
you a question let's just say we go
there because you know Republicans are
like let's impeach the guy okay fine but
let's just what you're saying yeah but
the Liberals wanted to impeach Trump
twice and they celebrate the first time
in the history a president got impeached
to White and it's on their resume right
okay let's and then they're saying let's
resign them and then they're saying
Court martial right how should he be
held accountable to this I'm actually
curious right like Nixon resigned over
what Nixon Watergate which was what
today Watergate is like a step number
three it's like Watergate is nothing to
today done by both sides very Obama
literally did it and God nothing
happened no question about it so did
Hillary it's a very simple model but how
should he be held accountable not just
voting how should he build accountable
today because in a Corporal World in a
corporate world if I run a corporation
and I accidentally cost the corporation
85 billion dollars you know what happens
to a guy like me I mean it's like the
board is going to sit down and say Steve
Jobs we kind of love you but dude you
are fired and we're going to bring in a
Scully and we're going to bring you back
seven years later if you earned the
right but right what should happen to
this guy today why should why should
free enterprise have more pressure of
their job being fired in the moment but
government employees they can just sit
there and say dude no one's going to
fire me what should happen today well
that's the problem that is the very
essence of the issue with authoritarian
regimes communism socialism however you
want to call it there is no
accountability in government we talked
about it before it's not your money it's
somebody else's money and and if you
blow it you know on a micro scale we
talked about build De Blasio's wife Bill
De Blasio's wife made a billion dollars
a billion dollars of taxpayer money
disappear there wasn't an investigation
there wasn't criminal charges she got
promoted she is now handling the
dissemination of the funds so what
should be done well by the way there's
two people that look very good right now
there's two people that look very good
right now one of them you know the other
one is Jimmy Carter okay how how does
Jimmy Carter look good right now yes who
did better him or uh Biden Biden is
making Carter look good Biden is making
Carta Carta sitting there saying at
least I'll be able to say I'm not the
worst of all George Bush and Dick Cheney
are skating by on this and I they look
Biden's bad but Bush and Cheney need to
need to have the the spotlight shine on
him Cheney especially because he's back
this time around in this Camp you know
Donald Rumsfeld your boy I hate him hey
horrible horrible horrible human being
rumsville no no Vice was a great
audience you did not see Vice you're
kidding me nah why why why like I've
been uh Hollywood doesn't like a
republican I think to answer your
question genuinely I think it's a little
too early let's listen folks everybody
Adam's going to give his I think it's a
little too early to just start dishing
out blame yes this is going not
according to plan correct okay cool I
don't think anybody likes to see what's
going on here but let's see what the
long-term ramifications of this the
bottom line is this
Americans overwhelmingly did not want to
be in Afghanistan let's not just like
gloss over that for years and years
already addressed that okay but for
years and years we paid zero attention
to this for years and years our military
our government was lying basically
saying everything's fine don't worry
about Afghanistan we got it all under
control turns out they were lying the
entire time turns out we could not
control 75 000 Taliban fighters turns
out 75 000 people fighting for their
Homeland fighting for infidels is a lot
more powerful than any amount of army
that's getting paid to play well you
don't have to win you just have to
stalemate it's how we put the British to
get this country but stalemate for how
long 20 years 100 years
I think the bottom line is I think we
have way too many internal issues in
America to be worried about Afghanistan
it sucks what's going on short term
right now but with everything that's
going on in America
you name the list of issues debt
obviously our tax system Health Care
homelessness the list goes on and on and
on yeah now we're now we're worried
about the Afghani people with all due
respect we've got enough questions no no
but this has got nothing to do with
Afghani people
what what does this have to do with
Afghanistan what what what part of this
issue is Afghani people
what part of yeah what part of this is
Afghani people
I mean you're saying yeah you're saying
let's forgive we have so many issues
here let's forget about that you know
the people in Afghanistan but let's
address our issues nobody disagrees but
is this an Afghani people issue
no this is an American government
spending and focus issue this is this is
this is a this is a this is a strategic
issue okay if you hire a c-suite
executive
you hire a c-suite executive because
you're expecting this person to be
competent in what areas and whatever
their specific experts specialize in
right okay if I'm a CMO my job is to do
a great job and watch just like you're a
general in the Army I expect to be
competent at leading an army exactly
what level of Competency did you see in
this move that took place two weeks ago
that's the question that we all have is
who's the one actually what I'm saying
to you is you're saying we already have
so many problems this could have been
prevented if the level of Competency was
done in a different way this is not a
issue that we disagree in this is an
issue of Competency this is an issue of
Common Sense this is an issue of basic
strategy for a person that in 113
billion people have been born from day
one till today you see that statistic of
how many people have lived there's only
been 46 positions for U.S presidents
he's one of them don't you think there
needs to be a little bit more competency
when it comes down to issues like this
that's the only thing I'm questioning we
talked last night crazy I asked Gerard
last night if you're comfortable
answering this you can say it on camera
I asked Gerard would you rather have
Hillary Clinton as a president or Joe
Biden what'd you say Hillary Clinton how
long did it take for his answer
what did you say Hillary okay now here's
the question would you rather have Trump
as president today or Biden
on this particular issue or every issue
in America just no just just take just
take overall competency decision-making
process would you rather have Biden or
would you have Trump
on this particular issue obviously Biden
is failing there's other things that I
think is doing better than Trump such as
I don't think it's a binary option but
but I think it is still because I think
it's competency like I think I honestly
think as much as there is nowhere that
I'm gonna when they have a Hillary
Clinton autograph on my office
I don't seek for that but I honestly
maybe a bill maybe a Bill Clinton
autograph but you know I don't mind a
bill but you literally
this is not guys this has got nothing
this has got to do to me who's a bigger
badass Hillary or Biden who did not
Biden Biden wasn't elected to be a
badass that's not that's the problem
that's the problem dude this is a
competency issue and a leadership issue
folks if you're watching this right now
if you're watching this right now you
have two choices
you have Trump I'm sorry you have Biden
or Hillary who do you pick and by the
way this is like a interesting crowd
right who do you pick you have a bite or
a trump issue who do you pick this is a
leadership issue this is not about who
won or who didn't win the world hated
Trump because Trump was pushing
everyone's buttons he was the obnoxious
guy that's going out there and calling
you out hey you got a big belly hell
your nose is Big hey you got a big
pimple on your forehead that's Trump is
that fair to say that's his style he's
going to go and call everybody and just
get under everyone's skin well you also
turn the free money spigot off which is
why they really got really and then he
put all the sanctions on everybody he
decided like he said you know what I'm
gonna go from uh a person everybody
wants to be like me a kid grows that
wants to be like Donald Trump rappers
want to be like Donald Trump I'm going
to go to be the most hated person in the
world by pushing everyone's buttons he
just woke up one day saying I'm gonna
push your butt in China Mexico Canada
everybody and he had the formula down
but when it comes down to situations
like this because your top position
presidency out of everything you and I
need to do in the job okay maybe ask
this back and we'll change topic because
we've got other things to get into
here's a question for you
tell me the number one quality of a
great comedian not top five the number
one you guys are in that world I have no
idea I think it's Charisma is it timing
is it Charisma you can learn timing I
think it's Charisma yeah
what do you say timing and Charisma you
put timing first or Charisma give me one
of them I just want we're reading the
room I said Charisma okay Charisma what
do you say
what's the number one quality of a
person that could win Mr Olympia that
could win Mr Olympia not be competing
for Mr Olympia but win Muslim I think I
know the answer but I'm curious what you
say you definitely have to own the crowd
okay I mean obviously if you have the
physique I mean that's that you have to
have the physique okay so that's number
one yes you have to have genetics you
have to have the genetics is that fair
oh absolutely if you don't have it it
doesn't matter like Chad nickel said I
can take everything I'm never going to
win the story correct you gotta have a
gift uh
okay let's continue what is number one
number one not top five what is the
number one quality for you to uh have a
girl go from being a girlfriend to a
wife
number one not top five
maybe a bad question for you right there
I I think uh every every woman says they
want to have a good communicator someone
who listens okay so someone who wants
terribility stability would that be
security stability Fair let's working on
stability he's getting stable he's moved
into his new spot I'm proud of you
what's the number one rule of becoming a
millionaire number save that goddamn
money okay so let's just say save the
money right what is the number one
duty of being a president not top five
not top ten number one protect your
people secure your borders boom you got
it so what I'm trying to tell you is
everything that happens this year
nothing is above securing your people
that's number one and he's not doing it
and Trump did
okay there's presidents that did he did
not do that and that's what you get held
accountable for that's accountability
that is the only thing I'm asking for
because you have to be competent last
night I hear [ __ ] in a backyard who has
to get up and grab the gun and go walk
around damn right I have to do it I'm
the guy that's the security of the house
I don't say well let me send my 79 year
old dad to go see a Jimbo yeah let me go
see what's wrong okay there's a big ass
possum on steroids sitting outside like
massive bench in three plays I'm like
freaking this guy
yeah so he's in the backyard
but but the point is the point is
competency security a husband a man
provides security competency for the
family a president has to give us
confidence that if somebody comes and
invades us or does something to us that
person is going to put the freaking
a level of fear and the other person to
say dude I'm pulling out I'm kicking
back listen
it sounds like you agree with Joe
bonano's book a little bit we need a
head of a family is that the idea Joe
bonano you're going back to Mom you're
watching way too much Mafia
[Music]
did the same argument we just need one
guy who takes care of everybody it's
like a father maybe you'd say a boss I
don't think it's just one guy I just
think like to me when you think about
somebody what are you gonna say okay
like right now you look at candidates as
the next president you got to think
about somebody that's going to be
protecting the nation you have to think
about somebody that's going to protect
them I think and make other people think
twice when they want to screw with
America I mean that's that's I think
more than anything else guys we as
citizens have to look at this and say
this Central planning can never work
because this is what's always going to
happen this idea that some government
some altruistic government is going to
come and they're going to take care of
everything they can't figure anything
out all it takes is one batch of Peter
Principle and ruins the entire Empire
man get rid of imperialism because it's
impossible and it's not profitable
except for a very few people at the top
capitalism is the way not imperialism
and also guys the centralized stuff and
now they're going to Pivot to climate
change they're pivotal the climate
crisis they're making Canada talk about
what happened in Canada oh it's all over
it's Australia New Zealand Canada where
uh Trudeau came out and said we're gonna
we're going to apply the lessons learned
from this war on covid in the war
against the climate crisis and all of
our environmental crisis and inequity
and social uh social justice and I was
like wait wait wait the Lessons Learned
like in New York right now today you
know I love talking about my favorite
home Soviet block New York City right
the the great Hugo New York it's it you
have
to show your papers
you have to show your papers you have to
show yourself
so you cannot get into the bodega today
yeah it's it's you can't eat groceries
without showing now here's what's an
asinine about this if you have a covid
vaccine you can still be positive
coveted positive and go eat in a
restaurant but it's okay you you've got
your ouchy so no big deal but if you if
you test negative all right like Cole
Beasley if you test negative and you've
been exposed to somebody all right who
who did a test but they but they
complied it's okay they can feed their
children did you see the article I sent
yesterday
um I don't even know if we want to get
into yeah phds oh yes
you know what we should care more about
the channel
than anyone hears opinions let's get the
channel taken down let's do it who needs
the channel
but let me ask you this it was a great
article if anybody wants to get this
article send me a tweet at Patrick but
David maybe later on today I'll share
the article with you it's a very
interesting article sent To Us by one of
our good friends here so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye-bye
[Music]